is there any character that can
seriously challenge
zoro's loyalty towards his captain
monkey d luffy the first mate of the
straw hat pirates that stood side by
side with the future king of the pirates
against the strongest creature in the
world that was willing to sacrifice his
life and dreams at multiple occasions
swearing his allegiance and resolve to
become the strongest swordsman in the
world to luffy while almost bleeding to
death a man so powerful that he was able
to cut kaido a feat that only kozuki
oden the strongest of the samurai wanna
was capable of doing and a user of
congress hot usually a sign that a
person is meant to lead and rule and not
follow another man by the way not the
only thing that he has in common with
the dark king silva's rayleigh another
absolute legend of the story who was the
right-hand man of goldie roger the first
pirate king so how is it that zorro is
willing to sacrifice so so much for
luffy to the point where his loyalty to
his captain is an even more respected
and inspiring part of his character than
his skills as a swordsman his discipline
or his determination i strongly believe
that zoro is as respectable and awesome
as he is for his loyalty due to his
change and growth throughout the story
if he had simply been loyal and trusting
to luffy right from the start it just
wouldn't have had the very same impact
because when luffy first meets and frees
zorro and basically bribes him into
joining his crew zaro is very much a
lone wolf type of character that hunts
pirates on his own following his very
own path really you can very easily see
why zarro has the will of a king and
could have become an immensely powerful
leader on his own if he never had met
luffy at the beginning of their journey
i think it's fair to say that zoroz is
joining luffy as a useful step towards
reaching his goal of finding and
defeating mihawk and becoming the
strongest swordsmen in the entire world
these here are the five major moments in
the story that turned zaro into one of
the
maybe the most loyal and respectable
characters in all of anime and made him
my personal favorite character in all of
one piece in case that wasn't obvious
being completely humiliated and almost
killed by mihawk at the baratier his
objection to usopp returning to the crew
on water 7 his sacrifice on thriller
bark swallowing his pride and begging to
train under mihawk during the time skip
and of course pushing himself to the
brink of death during the raid on
onigishima so getting to face off
against mihawk so early on into that
journey before even reaching the grand
line was the best thing that could have
possibly happened to zara really this
humbling defeat against mihawk changed
his perspective on the world
fundamentally well i think we all know
that he was far from being the strongest
here at the same time he proved to us
his potential to be it and more
importantly i think his determination
for the very first time here he would
rather die for his value of being an
honorable swordsman than run away and
not only did he get recognized by mihawk
for this but more importantly luffy
showed that he was more worried about
his health than his skills as a
swordsman and he also showed unwavering
faith in zoro's ambition and dream to
make it a reality and so having seen
luffy risk his own life a number of
times already at this point for his
friends it changed zaro's view and made
him respect luffy for both his strength
and his willingness to die for the right
cause and values remember these are the
two things that are the most important
to zorro and so this feeling of respect
just keeps on building up with luffy
saving naomi and arlon park reaching the
grand line freeing drum island and
finally alabasta from the rule of one of
the seven warlords at this point luffy
has fully earned zoro's respect proving
himself as powerful enough to be his
leader now zorro is probably much more
aware of the hierarchy and his position
in the crew at this point than any of
the other straw hats because by
accepting luffy as his captain luffy
also now carries zorro's personal pride
and honor as a swordsman and so when
usopp disrespects luffy and then wants
to rejoin the crew without an apology a
bit later zorro sees this insult to
luffy as an insult to him personally
after all discipline and respect towards
those who are stronger than you are two
of the main things that he took away
from his wano training in shimodzke
village which we have seen a lot during
the wano arc as well and so i would say
that zaro is both right and wrong here
at the same time he rightfully teaches
luffy a valuable lesson about being a
good leader and warns him that being a
pirate isn't a game a lesson that luffy
later has to learn the hard way by
losing his crew and failing to save his
brother ace really should have listened
here at the same time however zorro also
hasn't fully understood yet what makes
the straw hat crew so special the fact
that everyone feels more or less equal
and is free to express who they are and
what they believe freely and so only a
little later during the invasion of
water 7 when he fights together side by
side with usop and sees his
determination and willingness to fight
and overcome his cowardice does zorro
finally understand how usop has felt and
why he wanted to leave the crew in the
first place all while luffy is proving
for the very first time that he will
literally do anything wage war on the
government if need be to get a member of
his straw hat family back even though
robin in theory also had left the crew
just as luffy would later do with sanji
as well in whole cake island so zorro
has now become a very important anchor
for luffy teaching him to take things
seriously and become a better leader
overall while at the same time also
learning to appreciate the love and care
the crew has for each other and that is
actually something i personally feel
like a lot of people tend to overlook
here and just another reason i think
that makes sorrow so so awesome
literally taking on all of luffy's pain
without so much as a second of
hesitation on thriller bark then is
probably still my favorite moment in the
entire story up to this point it's just
so much
raw emotion like legit whenever you feel
like you need a good cry just rewatch
this scene in case you forgot zorro is
already pretty much unable to stand up
himself when he blocks kuma's path to an
unconscious luffy he bargains for him to
let luffy go in exchange for his own
life kuma then kindly enough i guess
takes him up on that offer and using his
unique devil fruit powers extracts all
of the damage and pain that luffy has
accumulated during his fight and gives
zorro just a small taste of it which
already brings him to his knees he then
lets him know that taking in the rest of
this pain will kill him quick side note
since kuma was actually not an enemy as
we now know i suppose he probably made
sure that zoro would not actually die
but he didn't exactly hold back either
as we can see and zorro does not know
this of course and yet without so much
as a moment of hesitation he just steps
right into that bubble which then of
course leads to the most epic moment of
all time where sanji finds him standing
there bleeding telling him that nothing
happens now this is of course the
ultimate sacrifice he's willing to make
here for luffy he puts the dream of his
captain and the way he's able to change
the world above his own dream zorro has
completely left behind the idea that
luffy is merely a stepping stone for
himself luffy's dream is now also his
dream or part of his dream but it does
get even crazier from here because
remember how zoro knocked out sanji who
was by the way to be fair also willing
to sacrifice himself as well well zoro
not only is prepared to give his life
for luffy clearly when necessary but for
every single member of the crew
including of course sanji despite all
their brawls and it really shows to me
that zoro at this point has fully
internalized that the straw hats are not
only a crew of pirates but a family and
so as luffy's right-hand man and kind of
the vice head of this family it's his
responsibility to step in and give his
everything to protect the crew as a
whole this crew has now become the most
valuable thing in his entire life and so
all of this goes to the next level when
zorro is sent to mihawk's island after
sabaodi because after seeing that luffy
lost ace during the war he throws away
his honor and begs mihawk to train him
at first mihawk's reaction to this is
being absolutely disgusted he thinks
that zorro is simply too weak to leave
the island on his own and that he has
lost all his pride as a swordsman it's
only when he finds out that zoro already
defeated all the mandrel monkeys and
decided to stay behind anyways that he
does see the truth of the matter zorro
has made luffy's dream part of his own
and he wants to make luffy the king of
the pirates above all else he wants to
become the strongest swordsman in order
to help his captain get there and
protect his crew from ever having to
suffer through something like on saba
odi ever again and so in this moment
he's willing to throw away his personal
honor as a swordsman what used to be his
biggest value in life because his honor
as a vice captain of the straw hat crew
is now much more important to him i've
actually made an entire video about
mihawk in the situation explaining his
crazy character development during and
after the war so if you want the whole
story check that out but in short for
here mihawk has learned luffy's crazy
power and potential during marineford a
man who got the respect of both shanks
and whitebeard and thus in the end
decides to train zorro and acknowledges
him as a worthy swordsman and apprentice
of his in other words mihawk really sees
how much zorro has grown as a person and
grows himself and so not only does this
turn zorro into one of these strongest
people in one piece after the time skip
but it also earns him a crazy bounty of
320 000 berries which i'm honestly
really jealous of i have 580 000 subs
right now which if it were dollars and
converted to berries would be 58 million
very bounty for me by comparison even
treble a man that consists to 99 of
slime has a bounty of 99 million
so please if you want to help me
overtake treble by subscribing to the
channel and raising my bouncy that would
mean a lot to me which brings us all the
way to wano and an arc that's
coincidentally mirrors a lot of the
events we've seen during thrill of art
and so it might or might not be
surprising for you to find out that zara
once again has pushed himself across his
limit for luffy and the crew first he's
come face to face with kaido himself
side by side with his captain something
we honestly all wanted to see really
badly and then dealt some real damage to
the yonko earning his respect and
revealing his conqueror's haki to us
still one of the most hyped moments of
the entire raid so far and after taking
some heavy damage in the process once
again he did not hesitate for even a
second to take the wonder drug of the
mings that would come with devastating
consequences for his health just so he
could keep fighting without ever betting
an eye though zoro just takes it and
goes off to take down king kaido's
number two in command and one of the
most powerful fighters and antagonists
in the entire story so far that's
someone on the same level roughly as
katakuri who luffy had really struggled
to defeat the ark before and now once
again zaro has been pushed to the brink
of death where he actually saw death
himself with his cloak and his scythe
though who knows what that might
actually be all about in the end we'll
find out however right now if you want
to dive even deeper into zaro's
fantastic character arc and the
fantastic secret how he convinced his
biggest rival mihawk to become his
mentor you really can't ignore this
video right here